at the end of the 19th century the
Russian Empire was vast poor and largely
agricultural per capita income was about
1,500 modern dollars and the average
peasant may do with much less than that
suggesting poverty comparable to the
more desperate parts of Africa today the
average Englishman earned four point six
times more than the average Russian in
1890 Romanov Russia was overwhelmingly
rural only thirteen point four percent
of the Empire was urban as late as 1897
this nation of one hundred and twenty
five million souls had only two cities
with more than 200,000 inhabitants in
1890 st. Petersburg with 1 million and
Moscow with 800,000 and these were
largely Imperial cities although Moscow
had become the center of Russia's
nascent textile industry gradually this
backward giant was beginning to
industrialize and urbanize Russian
weakness during the Crimean War taught
the Tsar that rural societies have
difficulty competing militarily with
industrial powerhouses like England and
France in 1861 alexander ii liberate of
the serfs
this meant that peasants were in
principle free to move to cities
although in practice their former
masters still demanded significant
payment in exchange for allowing their
escape in the 1880s and 1890s sir gave
it tried to thrust russia into the
industrial age under vit and tsar
nicholas ii russia built railways even
across the siberian vastness tariffs
protected infant industries foreign
financing flowed into the empire and
cities started to grow Kiev and Odessa
both reached a half a million
inhabitants in 1910 these cities were
built up by local magnets like the
broadsky's who was sugar barons like New
York City's havemeyer's
Ekaterina Slav now yep a Petrov ski
became a Russian Pittsburgh combining
coal brought by rail from Donetsk and
iron mined nearby krivoy rog ekaterina
sloth whose name honors catherine the
great proved an early model for the
russian industrial city a formerly
remote place with access to natural
resources that became connected to the
wider world by railroads as the early
anti modernization czars like Nicholas
the first were well aware cities pose
risks to autocrats and revolutions broke
out in Odessa and st. Petersburg in 1905
industrial woods
in Romanoff control Poland rebelled as
well some farmers also rose up but a
general strike in the capital is far
more threatening than any rural concert
hall the Romanoff survived that round of
uprisings through a combination of
appeasement and repression but Nicholas
ii lost his throne and his life when st.
petersburg rebelled not once but twice
in 1917 world war one had left his arse
without enough loyal troops to dominate
the organized urban workers the
revolution succeeded just like most
successful revolutions because the
troops had lost their loyalty to the
tsar and were unwilling to fire on the
unhappy urbanites the chaos of the
russian revolution shriveled Russia's
great cities and shrank per capita
incomes to below one thousand modern
dollars by 1921 the population of st.
Petersburg shrank from over 2 million to
under 800,000 Moscow's population
dropped from 1.8 million to just over 1
million the new Bolshevik masters of
Russia had to rebuild the economy
Lenin's new economic policy was a
profound a mixed model more freedom for
farmers to sell their surplus grain plus
state-owned heavy industry and a small
entrepreneurial urban class of NEP men
Russia's incomes were covered to pre-war
levels and the cities came back as well
since Moscow was now the capital its
Imperial status turned it into Russia's
mega city with a population that
exceeded 4 million by 1939 when Lenin
died and Stalin pushed his way to power
this new Reds are wanted his nations
industrial might to rival the Western
powers starting in 1928 he instituted a
series of five-year plans that would
drive Russian manufacturing into the
20th century these five-year plans made
huge factories and cities that were
built to enable mass production Stalin
didn't mind starving millions and he
certainly didn't care about urban
quality of life or perhaps life more
generally many of the industrial cities
were in the East to take advantage of
mineral deposits and coursing waterways
during World War two even more
production facilities were moved toward
Siberia to avoid the threat of Hitler's
Luftwaffe in some cases Stalin's
industrialization expanded existing
population centers Ekaterina Berg had
been founded in 1723 on the border
Europe and Asia its name honored the
wife of Peter the Great and it was where
the last Tsar and his family were
executed in 1933 it became the home of
uralmash the Ural heavy machine building
plant which made blast furnaces rolling
mills and cranes from mining cities even
further to the east it also built
military material including the famously
durable t-34 tanks further east cities
like Novosibirsk the Chicago Siberia and
klezmer yosik expanded enormously during
the 1930s Novosibirsk had only been
founded in 1893 but it was a natural
transportation hub since it sat next to
the bridge over the mighty river of
Krasnoyarsk is about 450 miles further
to the east and it became a center of
the gulag system where millions were
forced to work in Stalin's factories and
mines in 1956 Krasnoyarsk industrial
advantage was increased by the opening
of an awesome hydroelectric dam
Stalin's industrialization created a
very special type of city the gulag city
population clusters around factories
that were developed by and for penal
labor Norilsk maybe the most extreme of
Stalin's industrial towns it is the
world's northernmost city with over
100,000 inhabitants and it did not even
exist before World War one nuria's great
advantage lay underground
in vast Siberian mines that contain
enormous amounts of nickel copper cobalt
and palladium a railway was built to
connect the city with a nearby port of
do Dinka and from there the minerals
could be shipped by sea to Murmansk or
up the river Yen say to krasnogorsk
gulag labor worked nor else mines under
offered horrific conditions more than
15,000 workers died from cold and
starvation in 1953 after Stalin's death
nouriel's grows up in nonviolent protest
not much came of that the gulag system
became slightly more humane and a
khrushchev but these eastern industrial
cities continued producing metal and
machines and misery throughout the
Soviet era
in the United States Rust Belt cities
like Cleveland and Detroit suffer
because their industries have shrunk or
relocated the very success of those
industries had crowded out other local
entrepreneurship
and their locations are far from the
sunnier climates that most Americans
prefer the problems facing Norilsk in
class now you ask would seem to be far
worse there never was any
entrepreneurship in Norilsk and the
climate is awful the air is terribly
polluted after 1991 Russian nobility
increased and people and firms were
largely free to move Moscow alone
restricted immigration at least
nominally this migration offers the
possibility of eventually correcting any
extreme Geographic imbalances created by
Soviet industrialization yet nouriel's
population remains at 170 thousand
workers stay because the Mayans offer
high wages wages that are apparently
worth losing years of life for Novas
abyss can klezmer yards have continued
to grow
Russia remains highly dependent on
natural resources and many of those
resources are in Siberia it is hard not
to think that eventually these cities
will see the same shrinkage experienced
in the American Rust Belt if Russia
becomes richer and its economy shifts
away from natural resources then
Russians will presumably also move to
warmer more humane consumer cities yet
for now
Stalin's Siberian industrial cities
remain monuments to a Russia that cared
more for industrial success than for
human life and happiness
you